قتل الناشط هشام الهاشمي في غموضهم
بالعراق فيروس مربى بعود ويرعد دول
الافريقيه تسع ظاهره شراء القرى المهجوره
في ايطاليا هذه الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها لكم
من قناه العربيه فاهلا بكم
جدل كبير في العراق اثارته وثيقه صادره عن
وزير العدل تؤكد عدم وجود قاتل الناشط
هشام الهاشمي الذي ارتكب جريمه قبل النحو
ثلاث سنوات في سجون الدوله الاعلان سرعان
ما تسبب بردود فعل وادانات على مواقع
التواصل وصدعوات لفتح الحكومه تحقيقا
بالملف والكشف عن مصير القاتل خصوصا بعد
تاجيل محاكمته لست مرات خلال الفتره
الماضيه رغم ان مراقبين اكادون قاتل
الهاشمي لم يهرب لكنه مود على درجها التي
فرضت عليه التحقيق
بشكل مثير للقلق بدا فيروس مارب القاتل
ليوسع رقعه انتشاره في قاره افريقيا فبعد
تنزانيا وغانا والكونغو وانجولاس سجلت
غينيا الاستوائيه اصابه 13 شخصا بالفيروس
توفي منهم تسعه اشخاص منذ بدايه انتشار في
البلاد ومنظمه الصحه العالميه حضت الدول
الواقعه وسط افريقيا على عدم اخفاء
الاصابات والابلاغ عنها مضيفه ان المرض
الذي يسببه الفيروس هو حمى يصل معدل
الوفيات بسببها الى 88% ولا توجد اي
لقاحات معتمده لعلاجه حتى الان
ومن افريقيا الى ايطاليا التي ازدادت فيها
شعبيه شراء المنازل او المناطق المهجوره
خلال الاعوام الاخيره حيث قررت مجموعه من
الايطاليين شراء قريه مهجوره باكملها بهدف
اعاده الحياه فيها من جديد الملاك الجدد
رفضوا تحويل القريه الواقعه في اقليم
كاليبانيا الى منتجع مشددين على انهم
يرغبون بالحفاظ
الحياه فيها مجددا فيما تعد هذه القريه
واحده من بين سته الاف من القرى التي
هجرها سكانها في ايطاليا
في مصر الان حيث صدق مجلس النواب على
مشروع قانون بشان تنظيم الهيئه العامه
للارصاد الجويه لكن المثيره فيه كان
الماده الثالثه عشره التي تنص على فرض
عقوبه تصل الى خمس ملايين جنيه لمن ينشر
اخبارا زائفه عن الطقس في البلاد العقوبه
تشمل ايضا نشره تقديم خدمات الارصاد
الجويه ايا كان نوعها او نشر اي معلومات
غير صحيحه خاصه بحاله الطقس على وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي او باي وسيله وسائل
النشره دون ترخيص من هيئه الارصاد المصريه
في تحضير غير مسبوق قاد ايلون ماسك وخبراء
بمجال الذكاء الاصطناعي حمله تدعو الى
التوقف لمده سته اشهر عن تطوير انظمه
تشارجي
في خطاب المفتوح الى المخاطر المحتمله على
المجتمع والانسانيه الرساله الصادره عن
معهد فيرجن اوف لايف قالت انه يجب تطوير
انظمه الذكاء الاصطناعي القويه فقط في حال
الوثوق بان اثارها ستكون ايجابيه وان
المخاطر ستكون تحت السيطره